-And now it's time to play
"Republican or Not"
with your host Benson Dubois.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello, and welcome to the show.
The game is simple.
We're going to meet some people.
And our contestants
have to guess
whether they're Republican
or not.
Seems easy, right?
Hello, contestants.
-Hi, Benson. I'm Jim Lee.
And, honestly, this game seems
pretty straightforward.
So I think I got this.
-I bet you do.
And how about you, miss?
-Hello, Benson.
I'm Michelle Flynn.
I grew up in Ohio, so I've been
playing this game my whole life.
Kind of an expert.
-Sure you are.
Alright, let's get started.
Let's bring out our first guest.
♪♪
This is Brady.
Now, he's going to make
a few statements.
Ring in as soon as you're ready
to guess Republican or not?
Alright, Brady, give us
our first clue.
-I think Facebook is evil.
-Oh, wow. Um...
Because they're spreading
disinformation
or because they banned
Donald Trump?
-Hmm. Not so easy, is it?
-Well, maybe we need
another hint.
-I would say you do.
-I buy all my produce
straight from a farm.
-Because you want to
or because you have to?
-I don't know, Miss Ohio.
You the expert.
Keep going, Brady.
-I respect pro athletes
who stand up for their beliefs.
-Which athlete?
-And which belief?
-Who knows?
It could be her.
Or him.
♪♪
No guesses?
Okay, then. Give them
their last clue, Brady.
-God, I hate cops.
[ Beep ]
-Okay. He is not a Republican.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh! Sorry, so close, but no.
Brady is indeed a Republican.
-But -- But he said
he hates cops.
-Yes, but he was talking about
these cops.
Well, better luck next round.
Let's meet our second guest,
Lacy.
♪♪
Lacy came here from Manhattan.
-Uh, New York City or Kansas?
-I can't say.
Start the clock.
-On Twitter my pinned tweet
is "my body, my choice."
-Okay. That's a trick. She's
talking about vaccines, right?
-Oh, if we only knew.
Another hint, Lacy.
-I support Caitlyn Jenner.
-In what way? Politically?
-Y'all are doing great,
just great.
-Give us another clue.
-Okay. My favorite comic
is Dave Chappelle.
-Starting when?
-I love my job.
Alright, give them another one.
-Last month I went to a board
meeting and complained about
a book being taught
in my daughter's school.
[ Beep ]
-Okay.
I definitely know that one.
She's a Republican.
[ Buzzer ]
-No, sorry.
-What? She was complaining about
a book in her kid's school.
-That's right. And that book...
The Bible.
Alright, before we bring out
our next guest,
let's hear about
today's sponsors. Jimmy!
-"Republican or Not"
is sponsored by
the city of Orlando,
where Democrats visit
and Republicans live.
Orlando. Back to you, Benson.
-Thank you, Jimmy.
Alright, let's bring out
our next guest, Liz.
-Good afternoon.
-Is that -- I feel like
I recognize her.
-Maybe you do.
Start the clock.
-I'm a congresswoman
from Wyoming.
I'm endorsed by the NRA
and have an 80% rating from
the American Conservative Union.
♪♪
-Nobody wants to ring in?
-Yeah, I really want to.
It seems so obvious,
but this game is weird.
-My name is Liz Cheney.
I'm the daughter of
Vice President Dick Cheney.
-She's the daughter of
Dick Cheney.
-Okay. Y'all are being
real tricky here, aren't you?
-I'm a Republican.
[ Beep ]
-Republican. She just said
she's a Republican.
[ Buzzer ]
-No, sorry.
Again, that is wrong.
-What? How?
-The Wyoming Republican Party
actually voted
Representative Cheney out this
week for opposing Donald Trump.
-But I am a Republican.
-[ Laughs ]
You might tell everybody that,
but it's not what
other Republicans say.
Like it or not,
you are the Rachel Dolezal
of the Republican Party.
-Well, I don't care.
I've been fighting for
Republican values all my life.
-Oh, that is so cute.
We will see you on MSNBC
in about a week.
Let's take a break.
When we come back,
we'll find out if these
camouflage pants
are Republican or not.
-Ooh, ooh, ooh!
Who's wearing them?
A guy playing paintball
or Rihanna?
-You still don't get it.